hey everyone this is kevin from
thechestwebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the hillbilly
attack i've had a handful of people over
the last couple weeks asked me to do
this specific video it's an attack on
the car com which starts out with e4 and
c6 from black preparing d5 striking the
center of the board attacking our e4
square right away with protection for me
c6
white typical responds with d4 and then
d5 i like to play the fantasy variation
in this
line which is f3 but the hillbilly
attack says oh we're not going to play
d4 and instead play bishop
c4 now i'm going to assume in this video
that black's always playing d5 the whole
reason you play c6 is to push forward
with the d5 and there's no real downside
from pushing forward with d5 because if
white captures black can recapture with
their own pawn and gain a tempo because
now the bishop is forced to move black
has two central pawns white only has one
central pawn i don't think this is the
best way for white to continue so after
d5
white's gonna play bishop b3
now before we get to the variations
we'll let you know this video is
sponsored by skillshare more from them
later in the video
now three lines we are going to cover in
this video one is the pawn takes on e4 i
think this is the most common line that
you will see so we're going to spend
most of our time on that but they could
not take they could decide you know what
i don't want to move this d-pawn that
does open up for the light square bishop
to attack my f7 square exactly part of
the reason we're okay with him taking
this pawn on e4 they could just play
knight f6 pretty common development move
attacking this pawn on e4 or they could
play e6 just solidify that pawn chain
say you know what i don't know what
white is doing over here but i'm just
going to play it safe solidify my pawn
chain and go from there so the first
line we are going to look at is if the
pawn takes on e4
now part of the reason we play the
hillbilly is to play queen to h5 in this
example now the hillbilly attack because
people will ask all the time you know is
this a sound opening should i play this
if you have normal time controls i would
not play the hillbilly
attack i think there's a lot of ways for
black to equalize but if you're playing
a faster uh game or you're just having
fun i think hillbilly attack is
completely fine to play you can see the
bishop and the queen are both attacking
the f7 square there's three different
ways that black can stop this one is to
play knight to h6 this knight is
defending the f7 square next one is to
play g6
and then you can also see pawn e6 both
of the first two moves were stopping the
queen and this pawn on e6 is stopping
the bishop on b3 so let's look at the
first one look at the problems that
black would have if they try to play
knight 2 h6 we're going to play knight
c3 attacking the pawn remember we're
down upon the materials we're going to
have to get that back at some point or
just have a really really strong attack
here if they try to hold on to it
because they can't play pawn f5 that
pawn is being pinned down by the queen
from h5 so if they try to play bishop to
f5 well now we can just strike away
right away at the f7 square remember
this is a huge weakness typically the
king is the only piece defending it but
they do have their knight so if we play
bishop takes f7 they can now take with
their knight but then their bishop is
exposed on f5 so they could now play
knight d6 attacking our queen
and our and protecting their own pawn on
e4 but then we could just play queen h5
attacking the king they play
you know g6 then we come back to e2 now
we have our knight and our queen both
attacking this pawn you can see their
king is completely exposed they can't
castle on the king side and once they
play c6 on the carl con difficult for
them to castle on the queen side as well
i don't think knight to h6 is going to
be the most common but definitely like
for you to see some of the threats that
black uh would be faced with if they
play a certain move so knight to h6
maybe not so much let's look at g6 from
here we're just going to come back to h4
we want to continue
and have pressure on our opponent so the
queen to h4 attacks this pawn on e4
maybe knight's f6 i think this makes a
lot of sense defending the pawn on e4
we're going to play knight to c3 pretty
common theme that you'll see in this
opening we want to get this knight
involved into the game attacking the
pawn on e4 while maintaining pressure
with our queen here
bishop to g7 fiance doing their bishop
they definitely want to have some
protection for their king you can see
all the threats that we have going on if
they don't uh castle pretty soon we
could have a pretty pretty lethal attack
here from now i like f3
and this is another common theme that
after they take here remember we gave up
upon a material we don't mind giving up
another pawn
in exchange for a very developed knight
here so we have all of our minor pieces
involved into the center of the game we
have our queen on h4 although you
typically don't see it here on the h4
square if they cast on the king side we
can castle as well we do have a pretty
active rook on the semi-open f-file we
can play d4 next get our dark shore
bishop involved into the game so quite a
few threats from white but you can see
we are down upon the material so you
need to keep the pressure up if you stay
back and let your opponent
develop all their pieces then you are
going to have a tough game in the end
game if they don't play bishop to g7 in
this spot they could play bishop to f5
trying to hold down this e4 square
from here we could just play pawn f3
same as before after they take maybe
they play bishop g7 at this point the
main difference is they've instead of
castling they've now used an extra move
with bishop to f5 and so in this case
instead of castling i recommend playing
d4 because now we can get our dark
square bishop involved into the game so
if they play castle on the king side we
can play bishop g5 you can see some of
the threats that we have once we
exchange here then this h7 square is
pretty weak because the knight on f6 is
currently defending it you also have to
notice that the pawn on f7 is pinned
down by the bishop so while it doesn't
come into play right away
getting into the late game that is
definitely something to keep in mind so
that's what happens if they play g6 if
we come back here after queen to h5
another option that you could see is e6
from here we're going to play knight c3
if our queen's not under attack we're
not looking to move our queen we want to
maintain pressure where it is and we
want to develop other pieces so knight
to c3 same theme as before attacking the
pawn on e4 if they played knight f6
attacking the queen and the pawn you
probably guessed it we're gonna come
back to queen h4 attacking this pawn on
e4 if they play maybe bishop to e7 now
we can take
they don't have to take if they want to
that's fine we can just exchange with
our queen here but then we can play
knight to e2 then we can easily come up
to f4 start to put more pressure on our
opponents
also defends the pawn coming to
d4 as well so just a few things to keep
in mind why we might play knight to e2
because we are going to be looking to
play
d4 get our dark square bishop involved
into the game and you can see because we
don't have the other central pawn from
white uh that that pawn on on d4 would
be
exposed from the queen on d8 which right
now it's not doing too much but it is
controlling the semi-open d file
before we get into the next few
variations a quick word from our sponsor
skillshare
if you're not familiar with skillshare
it's an online community where you can
take classes on pretty much anything
that you want it's also very interactive
so you not only learn something but you
can actually try it out and get better
one of the first courses i ever took on
here was around productivity i also
think this is one of the most popular
classes on the entire platform so i
definitely recommend checking this one
out and if you haven't tried out
skillshare before skillshare is giving
the first thousand people to use the
link in the description below or using
my code
a free
month trial so definitely check those
out and let me know what you guys think
we just looked at what happens if the
pawn takes on e4 which is what i think
will happen most of the time but they
may not always let's say they played
knight f6 okay well we're always going
to be pushing him with e5 now we don't
have to give up a pawn
in the gambits
but also we can force this knight to
move okay so where does the knight move
it could come to g4
uh it could come to d7 i think it's
pretty awkward if they just come back to
g8 and just ways to move with their
knight but let's look at both of those
knight two g4
the knight is under attack from the
queen but it's defended by its own
bishop on c8
we can play pawn d4 opening up for the
dark square bishop to get involved into
the game as well as protecting the pawn
on e5 because the knight on g4 is
attacking the pawn on e5 so want to make
sure that we are aware of that now we
can play
after bishop f5 we can play pawn h3
attacking the knight on g4 they don't
have to play
knight to f5 but usually they want to
play e6 at some point and so without
blocking in their light square bishop
getting it to f5 makes a lot of sense
you know just pretty common in the car
con so h3 but now forces their knight to
come back to h6
okay well now we can play g4 saying hey
if we castle we're probably going to
castle on the queen side so we're just
going to throw everything at the king
side from black when you look at pawn
structures typically where the pawn
structures the almost the arrow is
pointed that's the side you want to
start to attack so you can see with the
d4 and the e5 pawn those are starting to
point towards the king side from black
so we're going to throw everything at
the king side and have a really really
strong attack so after uh g4 here you
can see probably going to come back to
d7 uh
just going to get pretty cramped if it
comes back to g6 but either way we're
just forcing our opponent back we can
play knight to f3 again we're developing
our pieces we're expanding a little bit
in the center of the board still have
both of our central pawns here now they
could play e6 if they want to and then
we can push forward with
c4 start to chip away here right now our
light square bishop because they have
their pawn on d4 and e6 it's not as
threatening as it typically would be so
if we want to exchange and have some
pressure on this light square diagonal
or if we want to bring our our light
square bishop back to c2 we do have some
options now instead of coming to g4 for
black they could also play
knight to
d7 remember it is blocking off the light
square bishop but many times they're
just playing very very passive solid
structure from black but they're not
trying to get out of hand they're just
trying to make sure they don't make any
mistakes okay well from here we'll just
continue to
develop the center of the board get more
material involved so d4 maybe e6 from
black continue the same theme as before
and then i like c3 here for some of the
same reasons you can see it's going to
be difficult for this light square
bishop to do too much so this allows it
to come back to c2
if it wants to
maybe c5 uh knight to f3 here uh a
pretty common opening from from both
sides you can see these pawns eyeing
down on the king side so white's
definitely going to be looking to put
more pressure on the king side from
black so that's what happens if they
play knight to f6
early on the last variation instead of
the pawn taking or the knight take or
coming to f6 last version we're going to
look at is e6
now from here we're going to play knight
c3 not only attacking the d5 square but
more importantly defending the e4 square
in
the center of the board and i think
there's only two plays that you'll see
one is just pushing forward with d4
which i hope that they do we're almost
baiting them to play that when we played
knight to c3 or the other options just
completely avoid what we're doing and
just continue with the normal game plan
of knight f6 okay let's first look at
the first one with knight two d4
we're gonna come back to knight to e2
attacking
this pawn on d4
i think a lot of times they're going to
play e5 yes their queen is defending it
but just to have a solid pawn structure
in this in the board you don't want to
be tying it all to your queen so e5
makes a lot of sense but this is what
we're hoping them to do because
the bishop on b3 is now active and this
is where i like to have the light
squared bishop once they play their pawn
to
e5 and then if we can
get them to play d4 now neither of their
central pawns can ever block our light
square bishop on b3 so they've
overextended in my opinion we can take
advantage of that first with d3 so we've
solidified our own pawn chain opening up
for our dark square bishop to get
involved into the game maybe knight two
f6 here then we play f4 again blowing up
this
pawn on e5 we don't care about our king
side we're just trying to attack the
kings how we're probably even going to
castle on the queen side
if they take we can take with our bishop
here making it even easier to castle on
the queen's head we can get our queen to
d2 at some point castle on the queen
side pretty strong
attack there so if we come back if they
don't play d4 which we hope they do they
could just play knight to f6 we're
always going to be pushing forward with
e5 once we see the knight come to f6
but now they could play d4 we can
capture that'd be a huge mistake though
so just keep in mind that they may look
at it and say yeah i can play my knight
instead of playing d4 that's what we
expect them to do and that's fine and
then we'll play d4 so they don't play d4
but if they decide to go ahead and play
d4 and say yeah we'll just exchange why
i think this is going to be very good
for white we take they take
we take here on g7 they really need to
take with their pawn on d2 check if they
don't it gets pretty awkward because now
we can just take
and
we still have a fine uh structure but
we're actually
up in material here we have seven pawns
they have six pawns they don't have much
to show for and their king side is
weakened so and instead of taking with
their bishop i think they really need to
take here now we take with our queen
uh we can exchange even if we want to
after bishop takes now you can see both
sides equal in material we can cast on
the queen side i think we're much better
off here uh their king is exposed i
don't think they want to
castle
on the king side
so all in all i think this is very good
for white but that is
the hillbilly attack uh from the very
beginning that bishop to c4 hopefully
you guys enjoyed this
not too many openings that you'll see
against the karo khan so like to like to
mix it up a little bit especially as
i've had requests to make this but thank
you guys so much for watching this video
if you have more recommendations let me
know and i'll see you guys in the next
one